everything in night city has a price
some things are painful with a deadly
dose of iron while
others require cash if you want high-end
weapons slick cybernetics fast cars and
stylish clothes
you'll need a lot of dough
job and all the rest of that corporal
[ __ ] you know what it is
[Music]
the most straightforward way to earn
money or eddies is by simply playing
through the story
as you explore the world and complete
quests you'll earn a decent amount of
money
however as you explore opulent clubs
rundown warehouses and seedy back alleys
there are a few things to keep in mind
in order to maximize your profits
the first one is standard open world
fair loot everything from file cabinets
to corpses
most of the stuff you will undoubtedly
find is labeled as
junk junk can either be broken down into
crafting components or sold to vendors
with the touch of a button
praise the sell all junk option however
you'll want to balance your junk
collecting with your overall encumbrance
and the value of said piece of junk
when you look at a piece of junk a
window will pop up that will show you
the weight and value
typically i ignore things under 10 bucks
because i don't think it's worth the
hassle but hey
1v's trash is another v's treasure this
also goes for weapons and clothing
if an enemy drops a rare weapon that you
have no use for
sell it i've ripped valuable assault
rifles from the cold dead hands of my
enemies just to flip them to a nearby
gun store do i feel bad
maybe but some of the guns i've found
are worth well over 1 000 eddies
the next thing you should keep an eye
out for as you explore are hackable
computers
if you're a savvy netrunner you can hack
into access points and transfer funds
directly into your account
the better you do the more money you'll
make there are also a number of passive
perks tied to this action in the
intelligence tree that can make hacking
easier and net you even more cash
one in particular worth grabbing is the
advanced datamined perk which lets you
transfer even more money after a
successful hack
well well who do i spy but v
in my humble parlor no less mucaco
long time no see as you explore night
city and get acquainted with the various
fixtures in each district you'll get
hired for small gigs
most of these gigs are pretty
straightforward off a few gang members
steal a laptop or incapacitate or kill
a wanted criminal these jobs usually
only last for a few minutes and you will
earn a good bit of cash
the bounty gigs coordinated by the
district's fixer are my favorite you'll
get a text with an image of your target
and their info and it's up to you to
decide how to deal with them these are
indicated with a small wanted poster on
the map
it's also worth noting that money isn't
a guaranteed reward for each and every
quest
sometimes it's a rare iconic weapon and
other times it's the satisfaction of
helping out a friend in need
if you're getting paid for your work the
quest giver will usually let you know up
front let's
just say they aren't leap but
very looped one early questline in
particular that will line your pockets
is called apistrophy
at the beginning of act two investigate
the side job called human
nature and eventually you will be asked
to track down specific cars
each one you find and re-linked to the
delaman database you will get a nice bit
of cash
finally without getting into spoilers
there's a part in the story where you'll
need
15k in order to progress i'd keep this
in mind when you hit
act 2. those are just a few money-making
tips to keep fresh as you explore night
city
as always if you know of a good way to
make some extra cash let me know in the
comments below
for more cyberpunk tips and tricks make
sure to like this video and subscribe
to youtube.comgamespot until next time
you